this election is apparently going to be
rigged according to Republican
presidential candidate Donald Trump and
really what Trump is doing is he is
setting himself up to explain on
November 9th why he was completely blown
out it's not a guarantee that Trump is
going to lose in November but if you
look at the polling right now 21 of 21
recent poll say Hillary's ahead
state-by-state polling suggests that
Donald Trump will not even crack 200
electoral votes in November if that
happens you know what Trump is doing
Louis he is setting himself up to blame
his loss on the election being rigged
there's a new webpage on his website
which says you can volunteer to be a
trump election observer the page says
help me stop crooked Hillary from
rigging this election Trump is saying
Democrats are rigging the election and
that that's the only way he could lose
he showed up in Louise in I'm sorry not
only ziana Pennsylvania where he is down
10 and said the only way that we will
lose in Pennsylvania is if cheating goes
on well what about the fact that you're
already down nine point two point points
in Pennsylvania apparently that doesn't
matter here's the reason this is really
dangerous we know that the DNC was
involved in helping Bernie Sanders
defeat Hillary Clinton in the Democratic
primary so some people have a passing
awareness of that then they hear Trump
say the November election is rigged and
they sort of think that what happened in
the DNC proves that the November
election is quote rigged there is a huge
difference between a political party
helping one candidate to become the
nominee and quote rigging the way Trump
is describing so I am really worried
that this is going to have a very very
negative effect on a lot of people that
will be based in a sort of semantic
similarity on quote rigging and it's not
actually going to mean what people think
it means rights and there were those uh
in the Bernie camp who uh to them if
Hillary wins California there's no way
that could have been a legitimate win
right if Hillary wins in New York
there's no way that could have been a
legitimate win right and Donald Trump is
now doing the same thing he's he's
putting that in people's minds and even
if if if
it's looking like it's going to be a
Hillary victory uh I mean these people
are gonna change anything and they're
just gonna be furious but who knows what
they'll do when they're furious and
unfortunately people are primed to
believe this we have a quote here from
2014 from joseph kosinski and joseph
parent who wrote just before the twenty
twelve election we asked the sample of
respondents about the likelihood of
voter fraud if their preferred
presidential candidate didn't win about
fifty percent said fraud would have been
very or somewhat likely when asked if
someone was using dirty tricks about
eighty-five percent believe that some
candidate campaign or political group
was and this applies as the second
paragraph here suggests both to
Republicans and Democrats my concern is
that this type of voter suppression
right when we talk as as progressives
about Republicans wanting to make it
more difficult for traditionally
non-white liberal areas to get extended
voting hours or whatever the case may be
we are not talking about the rigging
that Donald Trump is suggesting and he
is very astutely here taking advantage
of public sentiment around the different
definitions of electoral fraud to prime
people to believe on november nine that
if indeed he gets blown out which he may
that it was all because things were
rigged he otherwise would have one very
very dangerous send me your thoughts on
it we're going to continue talking about
that